inyección tras inyección las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 están acercando al
mundo al final del túnel de la pandemia
pero su despliegue es lento sobre todo
en europa
calificando el ritmo actual de
inaceptable el director regional de la
oms e instó a los gobiernos a no caer en
la complacencia acz la aguda advertencia
llega un día después de que el
presidente francés anunciara
restricciones más estrictas en todo el
país gracias a las vacunas el fin de la
crisis está por fin tomando forma en las
próximas semanas aceleraremos aún más el
número de dosis que obtendremos y nos
convertiremos gradualmente en el
continente número uno del mundo en
términos de producción de vacunas macrón
dijo que más de 8 millones de personas
en francia habían recibido la primera
dosis de la vacuna contra el jove y 19 y
3 millones habían recibido dos
inyecciones el gobierno ha adelantado su
calendario de vacunas para empezar a
vacunar a las personas de entre 60 y 69
años a mediados de abril y finalmente a
todos los adultos a mediados de junio la
o ms dice que sólo el 10% de la
población total de europa ha recibido
alguna 2
y sólo el 4 se ha vacunado completamente
entre los países de la unión europea las
cifras son ligeramente superiores 13 4 y
5 6 % respectivamente para complicar aún
más los esfuerzos de vacunación en la
región alemania ha suspendido esta
semana el uso de las vacunas de
astrazéneca